starting off this hour is Kerry in
Minneapolis hi Carrie how are you hi
Dave even been better than I deserve
thanks for taking my call
you're welcome how can I help so I have
a question about doing a credit card
balance transfer for one of our credit
cards and wondering kind of what you
would recommend in that situation okay
and how much do you have on that credit
card about five thousand dollars and
it's at 28% interest
okay and what's your household income
total a hundred and thirty one thousand
how much other debt do you have not
counting your you have we do not own a
house we have two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars in debt
goal two hundred and thirty of that is
student loans good god who's the doctor
lawyer I am a lawyer okay and how long
have you been out of law school I am
just starting my second year practicing
so I'm still making a relative
politically modest salary okay so you're
making like sixty or seventy in your
husband's making like fifty right and
what does he do he is a computer
programmer that's good okay he may get
more razors than you'll get for awhile
okay and okay so we're hopefully heading
towards two hundred thousand in income
over the next few over the next couple
of years and be able to address this as
soon as possible well here's the thing
you can move the balance on your $5,000
credit card when you have two hundred
and fifty thousand dollars or the debt
you could just wave the balance and get
rid of it completely let's just pretend
that somebody just paid it off for you
today
it doesn't really change much the credit
card it's your problem you know your
problem is is no massive freaking
student loan debt yeah my real question
is so I am the nerd in her household and
looking through our debt snowball that
$5,000 falls I mean fifty five to sixty
thousand dollars down in the snowball
because you know five thousand dollars
if you have $50,000 worth of small debts
under three grand yes because the
student loans are broken up there are
multiple loans on each promissory note
so we have like 40 different student
loans that are all $4,000 right most of
them are under $4,000 so that's why I'm
wondering you know I don't want to
smooth momentum in the snowball but I'm
wondering like should we move that money
up or you I would you know here's the
thing okay so let's see 8% are 20,000
bucks don't you know if you move it blue
perfect if you move it from 28 to 8 that
saves you a thousand dollars in a year
yeah a thousand dollars in a year does
not fix your situation you know it's
really irrelevant in this huge mess you
guys have is my point and I just don't
want you to mean you can move the
balance if you want or you can flip the
thing up and pay it off quicker if you
want flip it up ahead a few of those
student loans and you know put it up
closer to the top I wouldn't you know
bump it up too far but get it to where
you're going to knock it out within a
year so it's not this interest rates
just stupid and it you know it knocks it
out knocks it out but I just don't want
you to feel emotionally like you did
anything because mathematically this is
not the issue
28% $5,000 credit card when you have to
and $50,000 in student loan debt is not
your issue you see what I'm saying it's
like 1% of your problem 99% of your
problem is stuff you didn't call about
and so ya move it if you want but don't
you know don't like throw confetti in
the air or anything cuz you didn't do
anything okay you follow me yes
so yeah either move it up in the debt
snowball and balance transfer it or just
bounce transfer it and don't move it up
to that snowball I don't care that's
fine but you're not going to balance
transfer your way out of this mess
right you guys are going to have to live
on beans and rice and you're gonna have
to work like crazy people get your
incomes up and clean up this disaster as
fast as possible hopefully you can get
your income up to 200 and then you know
you're not going to knock it out in two
years or three years
you know from today you'll be dead free
and but that's living on nothing don't
live like a lawyer because you're broke
lawyer and you know live on nothing and
just really lean into this on intensity
that's the big message here but again if
you want a balance transfer it's okay
it doesn't hurt anything if you want to
cheat it up into that snowball and
balance transfer it so that you get it
paid off before the balance transfer
deactivates on you and the 28% kicks
back in or something that kind of stuff
so that that'd be okay that'd be okay
but um but that's you know again if it's
not your issue hey guys thanks for
watching if you enjoyed this video click
the subscribe button to get the latest
content and check out these other great
clips from the show
you